russia's minister of defense sergey
shoigu distributing medals for bravery
pictures released for domestic
consumption to rally the people behind
what russia refuses to call anything
other than a special military operation
these soldiers made it back from the
front others have not
but it's a criminal offence in russia to
report anything other than the official
number which was 498 on march the second
and has not been updated since
according to mr shoigu the operation is
going to plan
in a meeting of the security council he
told russia's president that there were
16 000 requests from so-called
volunteers in the middle east who wanted
to help liberate in his words the people
of donbass
a claim quickly backed up by this video
from russia's ministry of defense of
fighters chanting their support for the
syrian president and for russia
vladimir putin went on to meet his
belarusian counterpart alexander
lukashenko a frequent visitor to the
kremlin these days who declared that
russia had acted not a moment
as both leaders reassured the other that
they'd weather the sanctioned storm the
u.s imposed additional measures removing
russia's most favored nation trading
status banning further imports and the
export of luxury goods to
russia luxury here has already shut down
the symbols of what it meant to get rich
in the 90s and the early years of
putin's reign all pulling out
instagram was banned today the symbols
of connectivity and modern russia
shutting down one by one
in soviet times people tended to talk
about the system only in the safety of
their own kitchens it was too dangerous
to disagree publicly and it feels a bit
as though russia is returning to that
state with the kremlin today with this
message to anyone who might disagree
with what they are doing a true russian
is never ashamed of being russian if
anyone says so this person is not
russian this person is not with us
many thousands of russians have left the
country over the last two weeks
sanctions will rip away the futures that
the rest expected they'd have
even if many may not really know it yet
dana magnay sky news moscow